bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de Socrate
on va changer un peu nos habitudes
puisque aujourd'hui on ne va pas parler
directement d'une pensée philosophique
mais d'un événement un événement qui a
marqué l'histoire de la philosophie qui
en constitue même si on peut dire
l'événement fondateur en tout cas pour
ce qui concerne la philosophie
européenne
à savoir le procès de Socrate
beaucoup de personnes savent que Socrate
a subi un procès
à l'issu duquel il fut condamné à mort
mais tout le monde ne sait pas de quoi
il était accusé ce qu'on lui reprochait
et surtout ce que Socrate a dit durant
ce procès
comment elle s'est défendu face à ses
accusateurs
et qui a fait que le tribunal d'Athènes
a fini par le condamner
vous allez voir que ça a son importance
parce que derrière la défense de Socrate
on trouve des éléments qui permettent
non seulement de comprendre sa mentalité
et son tempérament
mais qui permettent aussi dans une
certaine mesure
d'éclairer sa philosophie
vous savez il y a une phrase qui dit
tout est politique
parce que tout ce qu'on fait à une
influence sur la société ou dépend d'un
certain contexte politique
mais on pourrait tout aussi bien dire
tout est philosophique
tout est philosophique dans la mesure où
nos paroles traduisent notre vision du
monde
vous allez voir que les propos tenus par
Socrate durant son procès permettent de
comprendre sa pensée profonde
bien mieux que ne le permettrait
n'importe quelle analyse de texte
alors à ce propos ce serait un peu
compliqué pour le coup puisque rappelons
que Socrate n'a jamais écrit un seul
texte
qu'il professait un enseignement
exclusivement oral
ces Platon qui a mis par écrit les
enseignements de Socrate
d'ailleurs le mot enseignement n'est pas
vraiment adapté puisque Socrate disait
lui-même qu'il n'avait pas de disciple
mais qu'il avait des interlocuteurs
des partenaires de discussion
alors dans les faits c'est surtout une
question de terminologie parce que
Socrate avait bel et bien des disciples
ou en tout cas des adeptes
sur lesquels il a exercé une grande
influence intellectuelle
Platon j'ai cité il y a un instant mais
aussi Antisthène Xénophon
et d'autres un peu moins connus
mais il est vrai que Socrate n'avait pas
de disciple au sens d'abord ou il n'a
jamais fondé d'école
et au sens où il considérait que la
philosophie était une affaire
personnelle
une affaire personnelle c'est à dire
qu'il considérait que la philosophie
n'était pas quelque chose qu'on recevait
de l'extérieur
mais qui devait émerger de l'intérieur
c'est la fameuse méthode maïeutique la
maïeutique c'est l'art de faire
accoucher les esprits
c'est l'art de faire émerger la
connaissance chez son interlocuteur
sans lui dire quoi penser
sans lui dire ce qui est vrai ou faux
mais simplement en lui posant les bonnes
questions
des questions auxquelles il trouvera les
réponses par lui-même
permettant ainsi de progresser vers le
vrai
donner un poisson à quelqu'un vous le
nourrirez un jour
apprenez-lui à pêcher vous le nourrirez
toujours
c'est comme ça que Socrate voyait les
choses
on n'aide pas quelqu'un à cultiver son
âme en le faisant à sa place
c'est-à-dire en lui donnant des réponses
toutes faites
parce que ça ça ne marche pas
on aide quelqu'un à cultiver son âme en
lui posant les bonnes questions
c'est-à-dire les questions qu'il
amèneront à dépasser ses croyances
puisque le véritable ennemi de la
connaissance ce n'est pas l'ignorance
c'est l'illusion de la connaissance
autrement dit le préjugé
l'ignorance c'est l'absence de
connaissance
le préjugé c'est la croyance qui se
prend pour une connaissance
et il est beaucoup plus difficile de
désapprendre il est beaucoup plus
difficile
d'extirper de notre esprit des croyances
fausses que d'apprendre directement des
choses vraies
donc Socrate n'était pas un gourou ce
n'était pas un directeur de conscience
c'était un homme qui voulait que chacun
prenne en charge sa propre évolution
philosophique
que chacun prenne en charge sa propre
progression vers le vrai
et c'est pourquoi il utilisait la
maïeutique
parce que dès lors qu'on exerce sa
raison dès lors qu'on se réfère au logos
le Logos c'est la rationalité
la rationalité qui gouverne le monde
dès lors qu'on se réfère au logos les
réponses aux questions bien posées
surgissent d'elle-même
donc le bon professeur
ou le bon formateur en philosophie
ce n'est pas celui qui délivre un
enseignement
c'est celui qui pose les bonnes
questions
les bonnes questions étant les questions
auxquelles on ne peut pas répondre de
manière fausse sans s'en rendre compte
donc pour Socrate tout individu
possédant une raison peu accéder au vrai
puisque connaître c'est simplement faire
remonter à la conscience ce que l'esprit
c'est déjà
connaître c'est reconnaître
comme quand on dit qu'on reconnaît de
quelque chose est vrai
et donc pour faire remonter à la
conscience ce que l'esprit sait déjà le
meilleur instrument c'est le
questionnement
l'interrogation guidé par le Logos
donc pour ceux que ça intéresse vous
pouvez aller écouter mon épisode sur la
maïeutique de Socrate
mais pour aujourd'hui on va surtout se
concentrer sur son procès et sur sa
condamnation à mort
tel qu'ils sont rapportés dans deux
textes de Platon à savoir
l'Apologie de Socrate pour son procès
et le Criton pour sa condamnation à mort
donc replaçons les choses dans le
contexte
on est au cinquième siècle avant
Jésus-Christ
Socrate mène sa petite vie
il se promène dans les rues d'Athènes
et il aborde ses concitoyens pour
entamer la discussion
et un beau jour un poète nommé meletos
porte plainte contre Socrate auprès de
l'art controi
et ça plainte porte sur trois chefs
d'accusation
un piété
introduction de nouvelles divinités dans
la cité
et corruption de la jeunesse
alors on va expliquer un peu chacun de
ces chefs d'accusation
on va commencer par la corruption de la
jeunesse parce que cette expression est
un petit peu tendancieuse
et on risquerait d'en faire une mauvaise
interprétation
Socrate est accusé de corrompre la
jeunesse
sur le plan intellectuel
sur le plan de la pensée
mais les toasts affirment notamment que
Socrate ainsi que les jeunes gens
à ne pas croire dans les divinités
officielles d'Athènes
mais qui les incite à croire dans de
fausses divinités
donc on ne parle pas du tout ici de
corruption à caractère sexuel
on parle de corruption
philosophico-religieuse
et puis
il faut aussi tenir compte d'une chose
c'est qu'à l'époque en moins 399 donc
année à laquelle a lieu le procès de
Socrate
on sort de la guerre du Péloponnèse
et Athènes vient de subir une lourde
défaite contre Sparte
Athènes est humilié
la démocratie est renversée
et elle est remplacée par ce qu'on
appellera la tyrannie des 30
or certains estiment que Socrate est en
partie responsable de cette défaite
pourquoi
parce qu'à force de dire aux jeunes
que leur premier devoir était de
cultiver leur âme
ils en ont oublié que leur premier
devoir
c'était de défendre la patrie
autrement dit Socrate aurait eu une
mauvaise influence sur la jeunesse
un peu vous savez comme dans le film Le
Cercle des poètes disparu
dans lequel le professeur de littérature
interprété par Robin Williams
se fait virer l'université pour avoir
encouragé ses étudiants à vivre
l'instant présent
alors pour ne rien arranger il se trouve
que certains disciples de Socrate
faisait partie du gouvernement qui a
renversé la démocratie athénienne
dont notamment un certain chrétien
Socrate lui-même n'était pas démocrate
c'était plutôt un aristocrate
aristocrate dans le sens étymologique
c'est-à-dire le gouvernement des
meilleurs
et les meilleurs c'était les plus sages
et les plus vertueux
c'était donc les philosophes
mais sans entrer dans les détails disons
que Socrate est perçue par certains de
ses concitoyens comme un traître à la
démocratie
et comme un agitateur d'esprit
comme quelqu'un qui introduit dans les
consciences des idées dangereuses
des idées qui représentent une menace
pour l'ordre public et pour le
fonctionnement de la cité
donc pour en revenir à la corruption de
la jeunesse c'est ça qui est reprocha
Socrate
de détourner la jeunesse de la religion
officielle d'Athènes
de la détourner de son devoir militaire
bref de la détourner de l'obéissance et
du conformisme
ça c'est le premier chef d'incubation
le deuxième chef d'incubation on l'a dit
tout à l'heure c'est l'accusation d'un
piété
alors on peut regrouper cet accusation
avec l'accusation d'introduction de
nouvelles croyances dans la cité ces
deux chefs d'incubation n'en constituant
en réalité qu'un seul puisque dans les
deux cas il s'agit de dire que Socrate
ne croyait pas dans les dieux de la cité
donc vous voyez depuis tout à l'heure
qu'on est quand même sur un procès à
forte teneur religieuse
procès religieux à l'issue duquel
l'accusé condamné à mort
ça nous rappelle un certain personnage
en Palestine
alors il faut savoir que Socrate
contestait totalement cette accusation
d'un piété
il le dit plusieurs fois durant son
procès il croit dans les dieux
mais il dit aussi et c'est là que les
problèmes commencent qu'il est en
relation avec une divinité personnelle
une divinité qui l'appelle son Diamond
alors le Diamond ce n'est pas le démon
au sens du diable
à l'époque le mot démon n'est pas un mot
nécessairement péjoratif
un démon peut désigner aussi bien une
entité malfaisante qu'une entité
bienfaisante
mais le problème c'est que le Diamond de
Socrate on sait pas d'où il sort
son nom n'apparaît pas dans l'annuaire
des divinités athéniennes
et ça ça pose problème
alors quand Socrate parle de son Diamond
parce qu'il en parle tout à fait
publiquement il n'en fait pas secret
il parle d'une voix intérieure qui
intervient en lui non pas pour lui dire
ce qu'il faut faire
mais pour le détourner de ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire
c'est une voix qui l'avertit lorsqu'il
est sur le point de mal agir
et détails intéressants quand Socrate
sera condamné à mort
il dira qu'à aucun moment durant son
procès son Diamond est intervenu
sous-entendu tout ce qu'a dit Socrate
durant son procès les trois fois où il a
pris la parole pour répondre à ses
accusateurs
rien n'a été empêché par son Diamond
il l'a laissé faire
c'est une manière de dire qu'il fallait
que Socrate soit condamné
peut-être même que c'était prévu
mais ça n'en reparlera tout à l'heure
donc venons-en au procès lui-même
Socrate comparait devant le tribunal
d'Athènes
il a 70 ans
et il apparaît plus déterminé que jamais
les terminer à quoi déterminer à prouver
qu'il est un citoyen honnête
qu'il est un homme juste
et qu'il est même un bienfaiteur de la
cité athénienne
donc le procès s'ouvre et Socrate va
prononcer son célèbre discours de
défense
et dans ce discours il va expliquer que
s'il comparait devant la justice
ce n'est pas pour ce qu'on lui reproche
c'est pour autre chose
c'est parce qu'il gêne certaines
personnes et certains intérêts
les intérêts de qui les intérêts de
quelques personnages influents d'Athènes
dont Socrate aurait montré par sa
méthode maïeutique
qu'ils sont loin d'être aussi sages qui
le prétendent
en un mot Socrate pense que ce qu'on lui
reproche
c'est de nuire à la réputation de
certains dirigeants
on disait tout à l'heure que Socrate ne
professait aucun enseignement
qu'il se contentait de poser des
questions et de relever des incohérences
la méthodologie de Socrate c'est
l'examen critique
c'est le pointage des contradictions
et plus l'interlocuteur de Socrate passe
au prétendre sage ou savant plus Socrate
va prendre plaisir à démontrer que ce
n'est pas le cas
tout ce que je sais c'est que je ne sais
rien vous connaissez cette citation
et bien Socrate voulait que tout le
monde en arrive à cette conclusion
que chacun prenne conscience de la
faiblesse de son propre savoir
que chacun en rabattre sur sa prétention
à la sagesse
donc vous vous doutez bien que lorsque
vous êtes une personnalité publique que
vous avez la réputation d'être quelqu'un
de sage
et que Socrate vient fourrer son nez
dans vos raisonnements
vous risquez de passer un sale quart
d'heure
et accessoirement de passer auprès de
ceux qui l'écoutent pour un imposteur
la thèse de Socrate c'est que ces
accusateurs veulent le faire taire parce
qu'il représente un danger pour leur
réputation
parce que quand Socrate se met en tête
de prouver à quelqu'un qu'il n'est pas
réellement sage
qu'il croit savoir mais qu'il ne sait
pas
il y arrive
et ça ça crée des initiés
Socrate est parfaitement consciente
qu'il a gaz beaucoup de monde
ailleurs pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont
lu les dialogues de Platon vous savez à
quel point Socrate est pénible dès qu'il
prend la parole
il examine chacun de vos mots il dit
secte tout ce que vous dites
il part dans des comparaisons
interminables
au point qu'au bout d'un moment vous
êtes juste obligé de vous incliner
et ça Socrate on est conscient
et non seulement il en est conscient
mais il le revendique
il se surnomme lui-même le temps
d'Athènes tant
mouche qui mord
et quand socra discute avec quelqu'un
qui se prétend ça son objectif est clair
le détruire
le détruire pour lui faire honte
lui faire honte non pas de son ignorance
et de sa prétention à savoir
parce que c'est ça pour lui le rôle du
philosophe
révélez l'orgueil humain
révéler les fausses prétentions
les fausses prétentions sur lesquelles
on cherche à se construire une
réputation
la réputation d'être sage la réputation
d'être vertueux
la réputation de détenir la vérité
Socrate veut briser la réputation
parce que la réputation
c'est le règne de l'apparence
c'est le règne du paraître
donc de l'illusion
vous vous souvenez tout à l'heure je
disais que le procès de Socrate allait
nous permettre de comprendre sa vision
philosophique
parce que pour Socrate notre monde
matériel le monde physique dans lequel
nous vivons
est un monde d'apparence et de
corruption
de corruption au sens métaphysique du
terme
notre monde matériel est une version
corrompue c'est à dire une version
dégradée du monde idéal des essences
or de la même façon qu'il faut dépasser
le stade du préjugé pour accéder à la
connaissance
il faut dépasser le stade de l'apparence
sensible
pour accéder aux essences éternelles
il faut donc dénoncer les apparences
faire apparaître les apparences pour ce
qu'elles sont
du mensonge
un voile de mensonge
prétendre que l'on sait alors qu'on ne
sait pas c'est du mensonge
et ce mensonge Socrate veut nous forcer
à le reconnaître
c'est pour ça qu'il dit qu'il veut faire
honte à ses interlocuteurs
parce que c'est seulement dans la honte
qu'on se remet en question
tant qu'on fait illusion il ne se passe
rien
on continue
pas de raison de se remettre en question
si le mensonge fonctionne
mais dès lors qu'il ne fonctionne plus
dès lors que notre fausse prétention à
savoir est mise à nu
on peut plus faire illusion
on est contraint à la vérité
ne serait-ce qu'à cette vérité que nous
sommes ignorants
de même que le préjugé et l'ennemi de la
connaissance la réputation est l'ennemi
de la sagesse
parce que la réputation est construite
sur de l'illusion
pour Socrate avoir bonne réputation
parce que celui qui a bonne réputation
c'est celui qui a réussi à faire
illusion
à faire croire qu'il savait alors qu'il
ignore
à faire croire qu'il était vertueux
alors qu'il est tout aussi corrompu que
n'importe qui d'autre
au contraire celui qui s'est donné pour
mission de détruire les faux sanglants
donc de détruire les réputations
celui-là précisément n'a pas bonne
réputation
il dérange tout le monde
parce qu'on a tous une réputation à
défendre
on a tous envie d'apparaître sous son
meilleur jour
mais ça nous dit Socrate ce n'est que
pure vanité
ce n'est que pur attachement aux
paraître
le sage le sage authentique
c'est celui qui s'est libéré du besoin
de paraître
c'est celui qui n'a pas besoin d'avoir
bonne réputation parce qu'il n'a pas
besoin d'être reconnu flatté ou félicité
au contraire même
le sage c'est celui qui accepte d'avoir
mauvaise réputation
précisément parce qu'il sait que la
réputation
n'agit que sur ce qui s'attachent aux
apparences
le sage n'a pas besoin d'être valorisé
il n'a pas besoin de susciter l'adhésion
de la masse puisque par définition la
masse est dénuée d'esprit critique
donc avoir mauvaise réputation pour
Socrate c'est pas un problème
c'est même plutôt le signe qu'il est
dans le vrai
dans un monde où l'apparence règne
avoir mauvaise réputation
c'est être rejeté par les corrompus
mais le tempérament dénonciateur de
Socrate n'est pas la seule cause de sa
mauvaise réputation
il y a un autre élément qui participe à
l'hostilité générale dont il est l'objet
devant le tribunal Socrate raconte en
effet que l'un de ses amis cher et fond
serait allé consulter l'oracle de
Delphes
qui lui aurait demandé qui était l'homme
le plus sage d'Athènes
et que l'oracle lui aurait répondu que
l'homme le plus sage d'Athènes c'était
Socrate
donc vous imaginez bien les réactions
que ce témoignage a pu entraîner
l'homme le plus sage d'Athènes et puis
quoi encore
et puis surtout comment vérifier que ce
témoignage est vrai
au moment où a lieu le procès de Socrate
Cherif et déjà mort
donc la seule source qui confirme ce
témoignage c'est Socrate lui-même
donc pour la neutralité on repassera
mais que ce témoignage soit vrai ou pas
comment Socrate pouvait-il ignorer qu'en
disant ça il allait juste passer pour un
prétentieux
pour un élu autoproclamé
on vient de dire que Socrate voulait
pousser ses interlocuteurs à l'humilité
à ne pas se prétendre sage ouverture
et le voilà en train d'expliquer qu'il
est l'homme le plus sage de la cité
à quelle heure
mais si on y réfléchit en réalité c'est
assez habile
pourquoi
parce que comme on l'a dit au début de
cet épisode
Socrate est accusé de ne pas croire dans
les dieux officiels
or là
Socrate rapporte les paroles de l'oracle
c'est à dire de celui qui est en contact
direct avec la divinité
il utilise un argument d'autorité parce
que c'est précisément cette autorité
qu'on l'accuse de renier
c'est donc une manière de dire vous
voulez que je reconnaisse la divinité
OK
mais alors du coup vous aussi vous allez
devoir la reconnaître
et si vous la reconnaissez vous allez
devoir accepter ce qu'elle a dit à mon
propos
et si elle a dit que c'était moi l'homme
le plus sage d'Athènes
c'est comme ça
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
vous allez rien faire du tout
vous allez vous taire
provocation suprême
reproche à Socrate de ne pas reconnaître
les dieux et la Socrate dit exactement
ce qu'il faut pour que ce soit ses
accusateurs qui n'est pas envie de les
reconnaître
sachant pertinemment qu'ils ne pourront
jamais se permettre de contester
l'oracle
et non content de dire que les dieux
l'auraient désigné comme l'homme le plus
sage il ajoute que lorsqu'il a appris ça
il fut étonné
il fut même sceptique
il s'est dit ah bon vraiment
moi l'homme le plus sage d'Athènes
je ne peux pas le croire
quand on écoute Socrate
indépendamment de savoir si ce qu'il dit
est vrai ou faux
l'impression qu'il se dégage c'est une
impression de fausse modestie
de fausses naïf
et on sait que la fausse naïveté c'était
la spécialité de Socrate
faire mine de ne pas savoir
feindre l'ignorance
pour mieux mettre en évidence
l'ignorance de l'autre
Socrate était tout sauf naïf
sauf que là encore Socrate est très
habile
parce que même s'il donne l'impression
d'être faussement modeste une impression
ne constitue pas une preuve
et jusqu'à nouvel ordre la provocation
n'est pas un crime
donc Socrate dit exactement ce qu'il
faut pour à la fois provoquer
l'hostilité des juges
et pouvoir dire que cette hostilité est
une injustice
vous m'en voulez parce que les dieux
disent que je suis l'homme le plus sage
mais moi je n'y suis pour rien
c'était pas moi qui le dit
ce sont les dieux
et vous l'avez dit vous-même
il faut reconnaître les dieux
et ne pas contester leur autorité
mais le fait que le discours de Socrate
n'a pas convaincu les juges
à l'issue de son plaidoyer il fut jugé
coupable par 280 une voix contre 220
la peine requise contre lui était la
condamnation à mort
mais comme c'était la règle à cette
époque on accorde à Socrate de proposer
lui-même sa peine
en clair Socrate pouvait échapper à la
mort s'il proposait une peine
alternative jugée suffisante
une sorte de dernière chance
et à ce moment-là que phisocrates
et bien il commence à par dire qu'il
s'attendait à ce jugement qu'il
s'attendait à être jugé coupable
mais il ajouta qu'il était surpris du
faible écart de voix
sous-entendu
il s'attendait être jugé coupable par
davantage de citoyens
qui peut dire ça sinon un homme qui n'a
rien fait pour se défendre
sinon un homme qui a recherché la
condamnation
gardez ça à l'esprit
et alors qu'arrive le moment de proposer
sa peine
Socrate explique que la peine qu'il
mérite
c'est d'être nourri au pritané
être nourri au pritané c'est la
récompense qu'on accorde aux citoyens
qui ont rendu service à la patrie
autrement dit alors que Socrate vient
d'être déclaré coupable il explique
qu'il mérite d'être récompensé et honoré
quel culot
qui fait ça sinon encore une fois
quelqu'un qui veut être condamné
quelqu'un qui veut mourir
Socrate répondra qu'il n'a pas à
proposer de peine parce qu'il n'a rien
commis de mal
et que donc s'auto attribuer une peine
ce serait reconnaître qu'il est coupable
le seul crime qu'il est commis à ses
yeux c'est de pousser les Athéniens à
philosopher
à cultiver leur âme
et ça il ne peut décemment pas le voir
comme un crime
et la boîte conscient que ce qu'on lui
reproche c'est d'avoir semé la confusion
dans les esprits
lui estime qu'il n'a semé que des
graines de sagesse
que des graines d'humilité
être conscient qu'on ne sait pas
se dire coupable ce serait renier son
engagement
ce serait dire la philosophie est une
imposture
à ce moment-là Socrate mais ses paroles
en accord avec sa pensée
il assume
et il assume de devoir mourir si tu
allais son destin
être condamné à mort pour avoir
philosopher
quelle meilleure preuve de la corruption
humaine
à l'issue de ce deuxième discours la
peine est confirmée
311 voies contre 190
son est terminé
Socrate est condamné à mort
et c'est dans son troisième discours que
Socrate va nous livrer les informations
les plus précieuses sur sa philosophie
car nous dit-il sa mort est une
délivrance
elle est une délivrance non pas pour le
peuple athénien
puisque sa mort sera celle d'un innocent
et qui devront vivre avec cette
culpabilité
sa mort est une délivrance pour lui
car lui fait quitter le monde de la
matière
autrement dit le faux monde
le monde des apparences et de la
corruption
Socrate croyait dans l'immortalité de
l'âme
et plus particulièrement dans ce qu'on
appelle la transmigration des âmes
après la mort l'âme quitte le corps
et rejoint le monde des essences
éternelles
c'est de ce monde des essences
éternelles que l'âme reviendra pour
accomplir une nouvelle incarnation dans
le monde de la matière
dans cette conception les vivants
proviennent des morts
les vivants sont les âmes éternelles qui
s'incarnent de manière temporaire
et donc pour Socrate
mourir n'est pas un problème
mourir
c'est rejoindre l'âme des grands
bienfaiteurs de l'humanité
c'est rejoindre l'âme du Lys
l'âme de Sisyphe
s'est rejoindre l'âme des biens heureux
la mort n'est pas à craindre car l'âme
survit à la destruction du corps
elle survit à la dématérialisation
la mort est une délivrance à l'égard de
la matière
après sa condamnation par le tribunal
d'Athènes Socrate est mis en prison en
attendant son exécution
il reçoit alors la visite d'un de ses
amis Triton qui veut le convaincre de
s'évader
Socrate refuse il refuse fermement en
expliquant que s'évader
ce serait allé contre les lois et donc
contre les fondements même de la cité
la situation est ironique parce que
crie-t-on dit à Socrate que s'il refuse
de s'évader
on risque de lui reprocher de ne pas
l'avoir sauvé
vous vous rendez compte
Socrate est sur le point de mourir et ce
qui inquiète Criton c'est ce que les
gens vont dire de lui
encore une fois la réputation
au moment où ils s'apprête à boire la
ciguë Socrate apparaît heureux et serein
il a dit la mort est une délivrance
et en l'occurrence il ne s'agit pas
juste d'une formule
ni d'une posture
le combat de Socrate c'est un combat
pour l'incarnation de l'esprit
philosophique
parce qu'être sage
ce n'est pas dire ce qui est bien ou mal
ce qui est vrai ou faux
juste ou injuste
c'est savoir que nous ne sommes que de
passage
car la vraie vie est ailleurs
je cite
peut-être pensez-vous athénien que j'ai
été condamné faute de discours j'entends
de ses discours par lesquels je vous
aurais persuadé si j'avais cru de voir
tout faire et tout dire pour échapper à
une condamnation non tant sans faut ce
n’est pas faux de discours que j'ai été
condamné mais faute d'audace et
d'impudence et parce que je n'ai pas
voulu vous faire entendre ce qui vous
aurait été le plus agréable Socrate se
lamentant gémissant faisant et disant
une foule de choses que j'estime indigne
de moi chose que vous êtes habitué à
entendre des autres accusés mais ni tout
à l'heure je n'ai cru de voir par
crainte du danger rien faire qui fut
indigne d'un homme libre ni à présent je
ne me repens de mettre ainsi défendu
j'aime beaucoup mieux mourir après
m'être défendu comme je l'ai fait que de
vivre grâce à ses bassesses car ni dans
les tribunaux ni à la guerre personne ni
moins ni un autre n'a le droit de
chercher à se dérober à la mort par tous
les moyens
souvent dans les combats on voit bien
qu'on pourrait échapper à la mort en
jetant ses armes et en demandant
quartier à ceux qui vous poursuivent de
même dans toute espèce de danger on
trouve mille autres expédiant pour
échapper à la mort si l'on est décidé à
tout faire et à tout dire seulement ce
n'est peut-être pas cela qui est
difficile à tenir d'éviter la mort il
est beaucoup plus d'éviter le mal car il
court plus vite que la mort dans le cas
présent c'est moins qui suis lent et
vieux qui a été atteint par le plus long
des deux tandis que mes accusateurs qui
sont forts et agiles l'ont été par le
plus rapide le mal et maintenant moi je
vais sortir d'ici condamné à mort par
vous et eux condamnés par la vérité
comme méchant et criminel et moi je m'en
tiens à ma peine et eux à la leur
peut-être fallait-il qu'il en fut ainsi
et je crois que les choses sont ce
qu'elles doivent être après cela je
désire vous faire une une prédiction à
vous qui m'avez condamné car je suis à
présent au moment où les hommes lisent
le mieux dans l'avenir au moment de
quitter la vie je vous prédis donc à
vous juge qui me faites mourir que vous
aurez à subir aussitôt après ma mort un
châtiment beaucoup plus pénible par deux
que celui que vous m'avez en mode jouant
vous venez de me condamner dans l'espoir
que vous serez quitte de rendre compte
de votre vie or c'est tout le contraire
qui vous arrivera je vous la firme vous
verrez croître le nombre de ces
enquêteurs que j'ai retenu jusqu'à
présent sans que vous vous en aperceviez
car si vous croyez quand tuant les gens
vous empêcherez qu'on vous reproche de
vivre mal vous êtes dans l'erreur
cette façon de se débarrasser des
censeurs n’est ni très efficace ni
honorable la plus belle et la plus
facile c'est au lieu de fermer la bouche
aux autres de travailler à se rendre
aussi parfait que possible voilà les
prédictions que je voulais vous faire à
vous qui m'avez condamné sur quoi je
prends congé de vous mais pour vous qui
m'avez acquitter j'aimerais causer avec
vous de ce qui vient de se passer
pendant que les magistrats sont occupés
et qu'on ne m’emmène pas encore où je
dois mourir je voudrais vous montrer
comme à des amis comment j'interprète ce
qui m'est arrivé aujourd'hui et en effet
juge car vous méritez vous ce titre de
juge il m'est arrivé quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
dans tout le cours de ma vie la voix
divine qui m'est familière n'a jamais
cessé de se faire entendre même à propos
d'actes de mince importance pour
m'arrêter si j'allais faire quelque
chose de mal or aujourd'hui il m'est
arrivé comme vous le voyez vous-même une
chose que l'on pourrait regarder et
qu'on regarde en effet comme le dernier
des mots or ni ce matin quand je sortais
de chez moi le signe du dieu ne m'a
retenu ni quand je suis monté ici au
tribunal ni à aucun endroit de mon
discours quoi que je voulu se dire et
cependant dans beaucoup d'autres
circonstances il m'a arrêté au beau
milieu de mon propos aujourd'hui au
contraire il n'est jamais intervenu au
cours même du débat pour s'opposer à
aucun de mes actes ni à aucune de mes
paroles à quel motif dois-je attribuer
son abstention je vais vous le dire
c'est que ce qui m'est arrivé est sans
doute un bien et qu'il n'est pas
possible que nous jugeons sainement
quand nous pensons que mourir est un mal
et j'envoie ici une peuvent décisive
c'est que le signe accoutumé n'aurait
pas manqué de m'arrêter si ce que
j'allais faire n'avait pas été bon voici
d'autres raisons d'espérer fermement que
la mort est un bien de deux choses l'une
ou bien celui qui est mort et réduit au
néant et n'a plus aucune conscience de
rien ou bien conformément à ce qui se
dit la mort est un changement une
transmigration de l'âme du lieu où nous
sommes dans un autre lieu si la mort et
l'extinction de tout sentiment et
ressemble à un de ses sommets où l'on ne
voit rien même mensonge c'est un
merveilleux gain que de mourir si donc
la mort est quelque chose de semblable
je soutiens moi que c'est un gain
puisque alors toute la nuit des temps ne
paraît plus un site qu'une seule nuit
d'un autre côté si la mort est comme un
passage d'ici-bas dans un autre lieu et
s'il est vrai comme on le dit que tous
les morts ils sont réunis peut-on juge
imaginer un plus grand bien car enfin si
en arrivant chez Hadès débarrassé de ses
soi en juge on doit y trouver les juges
véritables ce qui dit-on rendent la
balle à justice Minos radamante et hack
tryptolem et tous ceux des demi-dieu qui
ont été juste pendant leur vie est-ce
que le voyage n'en voudrait pas la peine
si d'autre part on fait société avec
Orphée musée Hésiode et Homère à quel
prix n'achèteriez-vous pas ce bonheur
quant à moi je consens à mourir
plusieurs fois si ces récits sont vraies
oh pour moi surtout quel merveilleux
passe-temps que de causer là-bas avec
Palamède Ajax fils de tel amont et tous
les héros des anciens temps qui sont
morts victimes d'un jugement injuste je
trouverai je pense un certain agrément à
comparer mon sort au leurre mais mon
plus grand plaisir serait de passer mes
jours à examiner et à questionner ceux
de là-bas comme je faisais ce disciple
pour voir ceux d'entre eux qui sont
sages et ceux qui croient l'être mais ne
le sont pas causés avec eux vivre avec
eux les examiner serait un plaisir
indicible en tout cas chez Hadès on est
sûr de n'être pas condamné à mort pour
cela et non seulement on y est de toute
manière plus heureux qu'ici mais encore
on y est désormais immortel du moins si
ce qu'on dit est vrai vous aussi juge
vous devez avoir bonne espoir en face de
la mort et vous mettre dans l'esprit
qu'il y a une chose certaine c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de mal possible pour l'homme
de bien ni pendant sa vie ni après sa
mort et que les dieux ne sont pas
indifférents à son sort le mien non plus
n'est pas le fait du hasard et je vois
clairement qu'il valait mieux pour moi
mourir à présent et être délivré de
toute peine de là vient que le signe de
m'a retenu à aucun moment et que je n'en
veux pas beaucoup à ceux qui m'ont
condamné ni à mes accusateurs il est
vrai qu'en me condamnant et en
m'accusant il n'avait pas la même pensée
que moi il croyait bien me nuire et en
cela il mérite d'être blâmé
j'ai cependant une chose à leur demander
quand mes fils auront grandi Athéniens
punissaient en les tourmentant comme je
vous tourmentais si vous les voyez
rechercher les richesses ou tout autre
chose avant la vertu et s'il se croit
quelque chose quoi qu'il ne soit rien
faites leur honte comme je vous faisais
honte de négliger leurs devoirs et de se
croire quelque chose quand ils sont sans
mérite
vous faites cela vous nous aurez
justement traité moi et mes fils mais
voici l'heure de nous en aller moi pour
mourir vous pour vivre qui de nous a le
meilleur partage nul ne le sait excepté
le Dieu
la mort de Socrate aura donné à la
philosophie une origine mythique
car c'est une mort qui débouche sur une
naissance
la naissance de la philosophie comme
aspiration à la sagesse
et combat contre le mensonge
sans la mort de Socrate pas d'oeuvre de
Platon
et sans l'oeuvre de Platon
pas de successeur à Platon
pas d'Aristote pas de stoïciens
pas de scolastique ni de Descartes
rien de tout ce que l'histoire
occidentale compte de philosophe
ne serait parvenu jusqu'à nous
si les vivants viennent des morts
la naissance de la philosophie vient de
la mort de Socrate
son Diamond l'a laissé faire
Socrate ce sera incarné pour se
sacrifier
ce sacrifié pour imprimer dans l'esprit
de la postérité que l'injustice existe
que la corruption existe
et que c'est le devoir des êtres juste
de l'empêcher de triompher
je vous remercie
[Musique]